هل هناك اي سياسات همم معالي الوزير ممكن
اتباعها في الدول العربيه اخذين بعين
الاعتبار كل هذه التغيرات يعني على
المستوى الفردي دوله دوله لا تستطيع ولكن
هل على المستوى الجمعي في الدول العربيه
يمكن يكون في سياسات يمكن اخذهم
في المستوى على الارض العربيه في الدول
العربيه بالطبع او شيء يجب علينا ان ناخذ
بعض الدروس من الماضي ونعرف انه حتى تحليل
الازمات الحاليه لازم همم تقريبا همم يعني
80% من الثروه التي خلقت في 30 سنه لفاته
كانت مربوطه بنسبه الاستثمار والابتكار
خاصه الابتكار والابداع كم كان همم للعرب
بالنسبه له هناك تقريبا 1000 مليار دولار
استثمارات في الابتكار سنويا ما هي نسبته
همم
ترقيم همم
الكبرى الدول التي نجحت الدول التي خلقت
اكثر ثروها ولا الدول التي اشتهرت همم
لهذه الازمات بطريقه اسهل للاذارات هي
الدول التي عرفت الدول التي بنت مؤسسات
وانظمه وقواعد وقوانين قويه وهذا المطلوب
هذه المطلوب هذا هو المطلوب الوحده
العربيه وليس كلام يعني
مصطلح قديم ومصطلح صعب يعني قراءه للتاريخ
وشوف مقاله الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
منظمين اكثر من سنه شوفوا الاتحاد
الاوروبي خاصه في الحرب بعد الحرب والدماء
الثانيه والدماء لم تجف وقرروا بناء شيء
كبير وعمله
هو مش ضروري يكون في وحده سياسيه لان تعرف
الاراء كلها بتختلف لكن على الاقل التعاون
الاقتصادي في المصلحه العامه للجميع همم
النظره البعيده البعيده نظره البعيده بعد
30 40 سنه يمكن من نص لها قبل هي همم نذهب
الى مرحله المؤسسات والقوانين والمؤسسات
العربيات والتي تكون مجدره او شبه مجدره
على الجميع وهي هذه نظره الشخصيه وهذه
نظره بعيده المدى تعرف انها صعيبه صعبه
الان ولكن على الاقل خلينا نقدم فيها لما
تكون عنها دهانات كثيره
هذه الان نعم العربيه المشتركه سوف نرسل
رساله قويه للعالم بطبع هي رساله دائما
لازم تكون ايجابيه وتعاون ولكن على الاقل
ما فيها اكثر ماديه مع النظام المالي
العالمي مع المنصات الكبرى مع الميتدارس
مع ال- ال- القوه الاقتصاديه الكبرى ال-
المشكله وين المشكله في هذه الفكره يعني
اقول لك العديد من المشاكل المشكله
الرئيسيه حصريا هي مشكله مفهوم قديم
للسياده ما هو مفهوم السياده لانه القرار
لان المر الى مؤسسات والى قوانين تجمعهن
نحن كرب هي هي همم مبنيه على مفهوم ولكن
ما هو السياده واين هي السياده لما تكون
مثلا السياده الاقتصاديه لما جميعا نسبه
كبيره
ما ما ما ما ما ما ما انا السواد ريده
اين هي السياده الماليه لما ما نملكهم
بالعمله الصعبه وحتى الدهون وقريره بره
حسب الخارج حاسس بس سياسييتها الاقتصاديه
لها الحق في ذلك ولكن نحن اا نحن من ما ما
ما ما ما ما ما له تاثير عليه
واين هو كذلك واين هي السياده الفكريه لما
انا وانت وابنائنا همم نقضي العديد من
المعلق الكبير في هذه المنصات
التواصل الاجتماعي
من يتحكم فيها ويقررون ما يبعثون من ماده
ولحدنا دخول بعض الافكار الغريبه في
مجتمعاتنا ولحدنا حتى في بعض الديمقراطيه
الكبرى هناك تاثير على على الانتخابات
فهذه مفهوم السياده لازم يتطور مع
الرهانات مع الدروس في الخارج
حسب
وليس هناك طريق الا بالوحده الفعليه والتي
لا تكون مربوطه ببعض الارادات لبعض
القيادات ولكنها تكون ملزمه ملزمه للجميع
وصدقوني اذا كان وصلنا للمرحله هذه احنا
وابناءنا او ابناءنا سنكون قطعنا شوقا
كبيره